hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel this is your host famous Tick
Tock influencer Frank Jew here again
today to talk about some systems design
today we'll be talking about two-phase
commit which I personally use a lot in
my day-to-day life especially with the
lovely ladies out there in the first
phase of the commit I tend to tell them
that uh I am ready to commit to them and
in the second phase I break that bow and
go back to being a sigma male so let's
get into the content of this video and
uh yeah get started okay so as I
mentioned today we would be talking
about two-phase commit so what exactly
does that word mean or that term rather
well basically uh last episode we
introduced the concept of partitioning
our database which is something that we
do when our data set becomes too big to
be stored on one individual node and so
what that means is that basically now we
often find ourselves having to write to
multiple physical computers at one time
for a variety of reasons the first just
being cross partition rights right
sometimes you make a right and it needs
to go to multiple different places and
the second is global secondary indexes
where instead of just having a local
secondary index where we basically index
all of our data per node we actually
take all of the aggregate data across
partitions and we split up that Global
index such that a piece of the index is
on every single node feel free to go
back to the last video if you need a
refresher on that so again why do we
need it distributed transactions we need
atomicity here because when we want to
write to multiple places let's say this
is node one
and this is node two and those guys
represent different partitions if this
guy goes through but this right fails
we're in trouble our database is now
going to be in an inconsistent State and
we are going to probably have some
incorrect reads which generally speaking
we don't necessarily want eventual
consistency is okay because we know it
will resolve itself but incorrect reads
will not those are going to be persisted
forever
so how does two phase commit actually
work well first thing I'm going to do is
show off the phase where it doesn't work
so let's say we have one node right here
this is going to be our coordinator node
and even though I'm calling it a node
what this might end up being is just an
application server
right like we have a client who wants to
perform a right and the client is
reaching out to our application server
in the application server is sending two
different rights to our two database
partitions so let's say we're going to
call this guy a coordinator node that's
going to be a new vocabulary term and
the first thing that coordinator node is
going to do is say all right I'm trying
to start out a two-fizz commit right
because I want to write to two different
partitions so the first thing it does is
right over here it's going to say
I'm going to reach out to node number
one and say I'm sending you message one
are you ready for it node number one is
going to look at itself and say hmm can
I actually go ahead and Commit This
thing I'm going to run a local
transaction here's my right ahead log
can I write it down is it going to cause
an error and if not everything is good
it's going to grab the locks for that
row so that nothing else can modify it
and it's going to respond back to our
application server with an OK and so in
the meantime from when this guy responds
okay until it hears back from the
coordinator node it's just waiting and
the locks are still grabbed now the
coordinator node or probably at the same
time in parallel is going to reach out
to node number two over here
with another message saying hey are you
ready to possibly commit message 2. and
so node 2 is going to look locally it's
going to see this message too and it
might say you know what I'm actually not
sure I can commit this either it's going
to conflict with some other right that I
have or perhaps I don't have enough
space for it and then it might respond
back to the coordinator node saying no
I'm not good with this so what the
coordinator mode has to do is actually
go and write back to Node 1 and say
abort
and it's only then that Node 1 can
unlock
so now I'm going to erase some things
because that is how this would work in
the case where we can't go through with
a two-phase commit right so I'm going to
erase this guy here I'm going to erase
the fact that we grab some locks I'm
going to erase the no message so let's
say now that we actually can go through
with the two-phase commit so again we
start with ready message one we start
with ready message two and let's say
this guy gives the okay
now what the coordinator node is going
to do is the following in its own local
commit log it's going to say hey we have
a transaction that I know I want to be
able to commit with message one and
message 2. and from now on if I happen
to go down you know let's say this guy
crashes it can read back from the commit
log to know that we can recommit this
thing so even if our coordinator node
goes down keep in mind that these two
are now both waiting to hear back from
the coordinator node and while they're
waiting they've maintained grabbing the
locks for all of the rows that are going
to be part of this commit then let's say
the coordinator node is ready to finally
send a commit and now it's going to do
the following
commit
and it's going to do the same thing here
to node number two
commit
and then now Node 1 and node 2 can go
ahead and commit that local transaction
so you know they're going to do that
they're going to put it in the right
ahead log blah blah it's committed blah
blah
and now they can unlock their local
locks
you know erase these guys right here
and then once they do that they can
respond back to the coordinator node
saying okay we're done
and that is all it is right there guys
we just have one coordinator node and
all the coordinator node is doing is
ensuring that both of these two things
either go through or both of the
transactions do not go through it's
important that they are Atomic so this
is not too complicated of a process but
it does have some caveats and some
complications that arise with it
so what are some problems that we
encounter when we see two-phase command
well for starters there are a lot of
points of failure so the first thing is
this we have a single coordinator node
and if this guy goes down nothing is
getting committed and if this guy goes
down after the commit point where the
commit point is the first time these
guys respond to okay now they're waiting
and they have all of these locks grabbed
and while these locks are grabbed no
other transactions can go through on
those same rows so obviously that is
going to be a problem that no
transactions can receive and that locks
are being held and again those rows are
basically Untouchable during that period
of time what if one of these receivers
goes down so our coordinator node is
going to be back up
right here oops accidentally deleted the
commit log let me draw that guy back
but basically let's say this guy right
here geez I gotta get my marker back
this guy right here is going to go down
if our Node 1 goes down
the issue there is that now the
transaction can't actually commit
because we can't get an OK from both of
those nodes after that commit point when
the first node said hey I'm good to
commit this
but now it went down for some reason so
what's going to happen then is our
coordinator node is just going to have
to repeatedly over and over and over
again send messages until node One
Forever Until It actually responds and
completes the commit so obviously this
is a problem too we have very little
fault tolerance here we've basically
said if we're past the commit point we
need to get this thing done no matter
what it takes we're going to try it
forever basically until we can get it
done
so what's actually the conclusion of
two-phase commit well basically for
distributed transactions which are
something that is a necessity for things
like cross partition rights or Global
secondary indexes they're very dangerous
because we run the risk of having a
failure and when we have a failure our
system is basically unable to proceed
thus things like cross partition rights
and Global secondary indexes in
distributed systems are generally things
that we want to avoid when possible
there are definitely other ways of being
smarter about how you Shard your data or
possibly even improving your data
locality with something like a nosql or
like a document store database that are
going to allow us to generally be able
to avoid these types of cross-partition
Rights so this is something to
definitely keep in mind as you think
about designing your own systems these
types of rights are very dangerous and
while two phase commit can be improved
and we'll talk about how you can do that
when we cover things like distributed
consensus and things along those lines
it's definitely something that generally
you want to avoid anyways guys hope you
enjoyed the video see you in the next
one